aquí tenemos un triángulo y vemos que el
lado que va a hacer es el mismo que va
de c a b por lo que este es un triángulo
isósceles ambos lados son iguales y
también podemos ver que la línea que va
desee y vamos a ponerle aquí otra
etiqueta vamos a ponerle de que la línea
o segmento que va a decir a d es
paralelo al que va de a a b también nos
están dando estos dos ángulos que están
en términos de la variable x y lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo es encontrar
cuál es el valor de x
y ya que sabemos que estas dos líneas de
acá y de acá son paralelas de hecho
vamos a extender un poquito más acá y
acá la línea para que vean que es una
línea completa esto nos dice que podemos
usar algo de lo que ya sabemos sobre las
líneas paralelas y transversales aquí
ustedes pueden darse cuenta que esta
línea que de hecho la voy a dibujar un
poquito más extendida para que se note
es una línea transversal a estas dos
líneas que son paralelas y voy a
extender bien esta línea para que se
note que es una transversal y ahora
podemos notar algunas cosas como este
ángulo x + 10 cuyo ángulo
correspondiente se encuentra aquí abajo
aquí también tendremos un ángulo x + 10
y aquí tenemos otro ángulo que también
va a ser x + 10 o también pueden decir
que tenemos ángulos interiores
alternados de cualquier manera este
ángulo en la base va a ser x + 10 y como
este es un triángulo isósceles pues
ambos ángulos en la base
a ser congruentes y ahora ya tenemos los
ángulos interiores de este triángulo y
vemos que todos estos ángulos están
expresados en términos de x y como
sabemos que la suma de los ángulos
interiores debe ser igual a 180 grados
escribimos 2x más x más 10 más x más 10
y todo esto será igual a 180 grados
ahora vamos a sumar todos los términos
con x que es 2x mas x mas x va a ser 4x
+ 10 + 10 aquí ponemos más 20 y esto es
igual a 180 ahora vamos a quitar 20 en
ambos lados de la ecuación 4x igual 160
finalmente dividimos ambos lados entre 4
y nos va a quedar x es igual a 40 y con
esto hemos terminado ya sabemos cuál es
el valor de x y lo podemos sustituir en
los valores de los ángulos
aquí tenemos entonces x más 10 igual a
52 x 40 es igual a 80 aunque no lo
parece aquí en el dibujo y nunca deben
asumir algo basados en cómo está
dibujado así que este de acá va a ser un
ángulo de 80 grados y los ángulos de
abajo son iguales por lo que tendremos
50 y 50 si sumamos todo tendremos un
resultado de 180 grados